we already knew that Donald Trump's
son-in-law and advisor Jared Kushner had
undisclosed meetings with Russian
ambassador to the US Sergei Kiss lyac
but we now have learned according to US
officials that one of the things that
was discussed during those meetings was
setting up a secret communications
channel between Trump's transition team
and the Kremlin using a Russian
consulate in the United States in order
specifically to bypass monitoring by US
intelligence they talked about this in a
meeting at Trump Tower at the beginning
of December according to the leak
Kushner told the Russians that he wanted
to do this because meeting in public
would look bad for the Trump transition
team so this is important for a number
of reasons number one we are now talking
about specific actions by individuals
who work at the White House we're
talking about White House advisors
that's number one number two this shows
intent right the entire point would be
to avoid having public knowledge of
certain types of meetings and it also is
sort of incompetence because do you
think that the caught the Russian
consulate isn't being monitored by
American intelligence in terms of who's
going in and out or communications that
are happening there so it's really like
a trifecta of incompetence here
disgraced former national security
adviser Michael Flynn who was forced to
resign because of his own problems with
Russian meetings was at this meeting
never a good thing probably not a
surprise and US intelligence found out
about the existence of the plan this is
amazing when Keyes lyac told his
superiors in Russia think about that for
a second we found out about what Jared
Kushner was scheming by the but by
virtue of his lyac reporting it to his
superiors in Russia and once again
confirming previous assertions from the
media The Washington Post
already had received a letter in
mid-december saying this is what
happened it wasn't confirmed now it's
been confirmed apparently the Russians
thought yeah this isn't really a great
idea cos lyac himself was reportedly
surprised and hesitant about doing this
Kushner's suggestion was too shady for
the Russians when a suspected Russian
spy recruiter
says you might be going too far Jared
you've got to be doing something really
French yeah especially because this
allegedly happened right after it was
clear that Russia meddled with our
election yeah so you'd think that if the
Trump administration was innocent when
it comes to colluding with the Russians
or just wanted to eat give that
appearance yes that they would avoid
doing something as brazen as this well
that's why this appears to be sort of
the closest thing to evidence of
collusion or attempted collusion we
don't know whether this line of
communication was ever set up this is
the the closest thing to evidence of
collusion that has become public so far
and the reaction has been pretty
aggressive current and former US
intelligence who have been consulted say
this would have been insanely naive on
Jared Kushner's part because it would
require someone from the Trump campaign
or a surrogate to physically go in and
out of a Russian diplomatic office on a
regular basis which again as I mentioned
would be monitored by American
intelligence it would be characteristic
of Trump's team to do something before
thinking it through and weighing the
consequences but here's the the just
amazing quote former acting CIA director
John McLaughlin told MSNBC's Lawrence
O'Donnell quote I can't keep out of my
mind the thought that if an American
intelligence officer had done anything
like this we'd consider it espionage
this was not an American intelligence
officer this was Jared Kushner the
president's son-in-law but it's all part
of the larger motif of Trump team
members trying to cover up
communications with Russia and we come
back to this time and again Pat if
nothing is going on why are they only
covering up or attempting to cover up
communications with Russian actors it's
also hard to believe that Kushner did
this unilaterally I think he must have
been doing the bidding of someone else
because of course Kushner is a young guy
he's not very experienced yeah and he
also has great job security being the
son of the president so it was there was
anyone to do it it would be him
imagine if he doesn't have the job
security that we assume he has that
could get interesting pretty quick we'll
continue following it today's episode of
the David Pakman show
is made possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy
see website Breitbart pulling their ads
off and you can get the free five-day
home Tryon from Warby Parker check out
their glasses I use them when I'm not
wearing contact lenses I started with
the free at-home trial they send you
five pairs of glasses you see which ones
you like you send them back and
whichever one you pick they will put
your prescription in - I like this
because I can actually show the glasses
to other people and not have to just
decide on the spot like in an eyeglass
store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS